and just ask when are you free in 48
hours time what time works and it sounds
silly it's so small but God it helps so
much because my team get frustrated when
they're not hearing back on their
candidates and it's every recruiter
feels it so getting that bind from your
client say look brilliant brief thanks
for giving us an hour we try and make
every briefing call an hour if we can 48
hours I need to speak to you again oh
that's that's quick that's exciting I
said yeah it is exciting but we're going
to need your honest feedback and we're
going to need you on the call and once
they've bought into that they tend to
see a higher percentage of the people we
then send yeah